let's say given this diagram right over
here we know that the length of segment
a-b is equal to the length of AC so a B
which is this whole side right over here
the length of this entire side as a
given is equal to the length of this
entire side right over here so that's
the entire side right over there
and then we also know that angle a bf a
bf is equal to angle AC or you could see
their measures are equal or this is
implies that they're congruent or they
have the same measures and it's equal to
angle a c e so this angle right over
here is congruent to that angle right
over there or you could say that they
have the same measure now the first
thing that I want to attempt to prove in
this video is whether is whether B F is
whether B F has the same length as C e
does bf have the same length as C e so
let's try to do that so we already know
a few things I could do a two column
proof actually let me just do it just so
that in case you have to do two column
proofs in your class you can kind of see
how to do it more formally so let's
write our statements statement and then
over here I'm going to write I am going
to write my reason for the statement so
let me just rewrite this just have a
formal two column proof so we know a B
is equal to AC so this is statement one
and this is given we know statement to
that angle a bf is equal to angle a C II
once again that was given now the other
interesting thing we have an angle and
we have a side on each of these each of
these triangles and then what you can
see is both of the triangles and when I
say both of the triangles I'm talking
about triangle a B F and triangle a c e
and they both share this vertex at a at
point a is a vertex for both of these so
we could say we could say angle
angle a we say be a let's call it be AF
angle be AF we could say is equal to
angle be AF or we could say it's equal
to angle CAE angle C AE and that makes
it a little bit clearer that we're
dealing with that we're dealing with two
different triangles right here but it
really is the exact same angle it's
equal it's equal to itself right there
that's our third statement and we could
say it's obvious some people would call
this the reflexive property that that's
obvious that an angle is equal to itself
and so we could say it's obvious obvious
or we could call it maybe the reflexive
property that an angle is clearly
reflexive obviously equal to itself even
if we label it different ways this angle
is going to be the same measure and now
we have something interesting going on
we have an angle aside and an angle an
angle aside and an angle so what we end
up having is that triangle so by angle
side angle we have the triangle be a F
so our statement number four I'm running
out of space right here statement number
I'll go down here statement number
here's triangle baf triangle baf
and let me kind of highlight it in a
little blue right here be a F so that's
this entire triangle right over here and
half of the trick of some of these
problems is just seeing the right
triangle so we started with this wide
angle we went through the side that we
knew and we went to this orange angle
right over here b b:a i'm sorry we
started at this angle then we went to
this orange angle across the side a that
we know is congruent to that side over
there and then we went to the side the
angle the vertex that's not labeled so
be a
at triangle baf we now know is going to
be congruent congruent to triangle we
start at the wide angle go to the orange
angle then go to the unlabeled angle
it's going to be congruent to angle to
triangle c AF c AF so this is kind of a
messily drawn version but they could get
the idea these two triangles are going
to be congruent see a sorry see a E I
should say it's congruent to triangle
see a E white angle orange angle and
then the unlabeled angle in that
triangle right over there and this comes
straight out of this comes straight out
of angle side angle this comes straight
out of a si and this is one angle and
this is or so this is the side in
between and these are the two angles so
it comes out of statements one two and
three and so they are congruent we know
that corresponding sides are going to
congruent so we know our statement five
I should do this a little bit neater our
statement five we now know that B F is
equal to C e VF is equal to C EB F is
equal to C E and this comes straight out
of statement four and we could say
corresponding sides corresponding sides
sides congruent sides the corresponding
sides are congruent now let's take it up
another notch let's see if we can prove
let's see if we can prove whether II D
is equal to e F so we let's just keep
going down this and see if we can prove
whether II D
is equal to EF I put a question mark
there because we haven't necessarily
proven it yet so I'm gonna prove that
this little short line segment II D is
equal to sorry not EF is equal to DF e D
is equal to DF e D is equal to DF so
let's see if we can prove this right
over here so the interesting thing that
we might at first it might not be so
obvious you know how do we figure out
some type of congruence over that but we
do already have some information here we
know that these that BA F is congruent
to CAE so we also know we also know that
this side right over here let me do it
in a color that I haven't used yet let
me see I have not I've been using a lot
of the colors and my palates are getting
a little too so we know that from these
two congruent triangles that side AE
side AE which is part of CAE we know
that we know that a e is going to be
equal to AF that these two sides are
congruent and the reason why is they're
their corresponding sides of congruent
triangles a F is the side opposite the
white angle on ba f triangle baf and AE
is the side opposite the white angle on
triangle CAE which we know are congruent
so we know that a e is equal to AE is
equal to AF and once again this comes
from statement 4 and we can even say
corresponding sides congruent same
reason as we gave right up here now
what's interesting here is you know this
isn't even a triangle that we're seeing
up here but this information that these
two characters are congruent help us
with this part over here because we know
we know that VA we know that or I should
say we know that a b is equal to we know
that a b is equal to AC that was given
and so we know we know that e b let me
write it over here and i'll make it a
little bit a little
messy right over here statement seven
I'll give us will give us some space
we know that B E is going to be equal to
C F so let me write that down we know
that V E is equal to C F and why do we
know that so let me put the reason right
over here let me try to clean up my work
a little bit this column has been slowly
drifting to the left but how do we know
that V E is equal to CF well we know
that b b:e the length of B E is equal to
the length of B a minus AE is equal to
the length of V ay minus VA minus AE
minus I should say a B I could just
that's how I call it up here so it's
equal to a B a B minus AE which is which
is the same thing
based on these last few things that we
saw as saying AC minus AF because a b is
equal to AC so that's equal to AC and AE
we already showed is the same thing as
AF AC minus AF and AC AC minus AF is the
same thing as CF right over here is
equal to CF right over there and we know
that because and we know this from
statement one we know it from statement
one we know it from statement five and
we know it from statement and we know it
from statement six actually we didn't
need we didn't need statement five there
let me see we just need one and six so
let's say we need this is from one and
six is what we had to do there so we
just know that look this side is equal
to that side this little part is equal
to that part so if you subtract the big
part - the little part this right over
here is going to be equal to this right
over here that's all we're showing so
this yellow side is equal to this yellow
side right over here now the other thing
that we know and this is straight out of
vertical angles is that this angle EDB
is going to be congruent to angle FDC so
let me write that down again
eight we know that angle EDB angle e DB
is going to be equal to angle F D C is
going to be equal to angle F DC that
comes straight out of vertical angles
vertical angles are vertical angles are
congruent or their measures are equal
and now all of a sudden we have
something interesting again we have the
orange angle wide angle side orange
angle white angle side so we know that
these two smaller triangles are
congruent so now we know and I don't
want to lose my diagram we know that
triangle B edie we know so statement
number nine we know that triangle B II D
is congruent so ve D is this one we know
that ve D is congruent to triangle and
we want to use the same size white angle
yellow side then orange angle Y dang
white angle white angle let me be
careful here white angle so B is white
angle E is the unlabeled angle and then
D is the labeled ain't the orange label
angle C well so we want to start C
unlabeled angle orange Langille so C FD
so triangle C FD and this comes straight
from once again orange angle white angle
side so angle angle side orange angle
sorry orange angle white angle side so
this comes straight out of angle angle
side congruence and since we've now
shown that this triangle is equal to
that cut triangle we know that their
corresponding sides are equal and then
this is our homestretch we now know we
now since these two triangles are
congruent we now know that Edie Edie is
equal to D F because their corresponding
sides and I could write that right over
here
II D
is equal to D F and once again the
reason here is the same thing up here
corresponding so we know we know our
statement nine which means they're
congruent and corresponding sides
corresponding sides congruent and we are
done so that was a pretty involved
problem but you see once again you go
step by step just try to figure out
whatever you can about each triangle and
you eventually get in there really the
hard part isn't so much the realizing
which postulate to use or how to apply
them necessarily but seeing the triangle
seeing that there's some information
there seeing that you can figure out B
by subtracting it from from by
subtracting AE from a be seeing that
there are two triangles kind of
overlapping in this star without arms or
whatever you might want to call it